تظاهرات في الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري وام
درمان دعت اليها لجان المقاومه بولايه
الخرطوم بالتزامل مع الذكرى الرابعه
للثوره ديسمبر
رافضين الاتفاق الايطاليه بين المكون
العسكري في السلطه وقوه المدنيه الاخرى
مشددين على محاسبه الضالعين في قتل
المتظاهرين
يمثلنا لانه في جزيره معينه من
الناس اللي هي شايفه نفسها هي وصيه عن
البلد وما من حقهم وما لم انه يعني احنا
دايما بالنادي للحوار السوداني السوداني
اول حاجه من ناحيه المعيشه ليوم الليله
مما قامت الثوره دي ما شفنا حاجه تغير غير
الزيادات وكل يوم الحكايه زائده وسلام
الان لم يتحقق منها شيء خلاص
هي امتداد للغلاب اللجنه الامنيه ليس الا
وتاتي تظاهرات في عقاب التوقيع على
الاتفاق الايطالي بين المكونين العسكري في
السلطه ومجموعه من القوى السياسيه في
البلاد اتفاق احدث انقساما وسط المكونات
السياسيه بين مؤيد ومعارض غير ان مراقبين
يرون فيه مخرجا لازمات البلاد وقد ينهي
ازمتها السياسيه
[تصفيق]
دعم داخلي توافق داخلي اتفاق عليه داخل
وايد دعم خارجي
المجتمع الدولي يفترض بان هذا الاتفاق
سينتهي الى ترتيبات دستوريه تشكل حكومه
مدنيه هذه الحكومه المدنيه تنهي الحاله
الانتقاليه التي يعيشها السودان
ومع تفاعل تطورات السياسيه في السودان
يستمر حراك الشارع السوداني وقواه
السياسيه وصولا الى حكومه المدنيه كامله
لتحكم ما تبقى من الفتره الانتقاليه بعد
مرور اربع سنوات لم تدرك الثوره الشعبيه
في السودان مبتغاها بعد اذ لا يزال البول
شاسعا بين الواقع السياسي المتعزم وتطلعات
المواطنين نحو حياه تسود فيها قيم الحريه
والسلام والعداله اسامه سيد احمد الجزيره
الخرطوم